des assises de la côte-d'or ont donc
condamné jean gay à 20 ans de prison ce
septuagénaire accusé d'avoir assassiné
son ancienne maîtresse une retraités
tués de 56 coups de couteau et de
marteau à talent il y a deux ans maeva
d'hamoir on vous retrouve à la cour
d'assises à dijon un verdict plutôt
clément comparé aux réquisitions de
l'avocat général tout à fait quinze ans
de prison c'est le verdict prononcé par
la cour après trois heures de
délibérations l'avocat général avait lui
requis 20 ans de réclusion criminelle un
peu plus tôt dans la journée je vous
propose d'écouter la réaction de
l'avocat des parties civiles
c'est une décision proportionnée peut
difficilement passer en dessous est
monté au dessus qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour quelqu'un qui a 78 79 ans ça
ne veut rien dire
c'est une peine assez importante mais
proportionnée donc je crois que la
justice ait été rendue pour l'accusé et
pour les parties civiles
les deux avocats de la défense ont
exprimé leur satisfaction au sortir de
l' annonce de ce verdict et précisé
qu'il ne ferait pas appel de cette
décision qu'il juge proportionnée jean
guay a toujours reconnu les faits c'est
la question de la préméditation qui a
fait débat pendant ces quatre jours de
comparution elle son profil qui a été
principalement décrypter et la scéne et
56 coups de couteau et de tournevis à sa
victime alors était ce un crime
passionnel ou un acte réfléchi
une vingtaine de témoins a déclaré qu'il
s'agissait d'un homme gentil et brave
quand ses anciennes maîtresses ont elles
déclaré qu'il était un tyran l'
expertise psychiatrique a conclu un
homme en proie à une rage narcissique
jean gay soixante dix huit ans avaient
peur de finir seul il terminera sa vie
en prison
merci maeva damois en direct de la cour
d'assises à dijon